all right uh let's start welcome uh
everyone to the ddps seminar uh today uh
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics
first of all please mute yourself uh
during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions by the
way uh you are welcome to unmute and ask
um speaker said you're welcome to
interrupt uh his talk uh otherwise
please use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out um finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today it is a
great honor to host yanis c c this who
is an yeah did I pronounce your name
good oh great okay who is an Emeritus
professor at Princeton University and at
the same time a professor at Johns
Hopkins uh he studied chemical
engineering at the National Technical
University in Athens then follow the
steps of many alumni of that department
to the University of Minnesota where he
studied with rudford Aris and Len Smit
as well as Don Aronson and Dick mcki In
Math he was a director's fellow at the
center for nonia studies in Los Alamos
in 1985 to 86 when Soviets still existed
and research funds were plentiful he
then had a good fortune of joining The
Faculty at Princeton where he taught
chemical engineering and also applied in
computational mathematics for 31 years
four years ago he became ameritus and be
started fresh at jnes Hopkins where he
somehow is also professor of
Urology his work always had to do with
nonlinear Dynamics from instabilities
and bipoc algorithms to spatial temporal
patterns to data science in in the 90s
nonlinear identification multiscale
modeling and back to data science ml
these days and he had the addition a
good fortune to work with a several
truly talented experimentalists like um
uh G aut's group in
Berlin when young and promising he was a
pecker fellow a presidential young
investigator and ulam Scholar at Los
Alamos National Laboratory he holds the
curn cast and Willam ERS of the
Ala the Crawford and Crawford and the
prices of I was young and promising
leave me some time to speak thank you
yeah all right he he's a yeah he's a
member yeah numerous numerous hours and
yeah today yanis will give a talk about
no equations no variables no space no
time all the new all the new results on
data and the modeling of the complex
systems please expect wonderful talk and
enjoy it and without F Ado there's one
last step um as usual let me um let me
ask you uh the one usual question what
you can answer these questions and then
you can start your talk okay what is
your favorite things to do other than
research yian
um I have a son who is an applied
mathematician so we chat for fun about
it I also play chess and I should be
doing more exercise than than I am doing
oh well same same here I I got to do
more exercise then yeah all right it's
stage is yours thank you so pleasure to
be to to be there I am in in rainy New
York I'm actually in a hotel room so
behind me you can see Mar dri and then
Marilyn Monroe it's an unusual backdrop
for such a talk and
um well okay it sounds a bit funny the
title so I have to justify it h but let
me tell you a couple of things first as
as usual the work has been done by a lot
of students and a lot of post dos that
were both very talented and patient and
some of them are kind of written over
here and then there's been over the
years many amazing collaborators for
example Rafi quman and I realize as I
use this slide that bill gear who is the
gear of Gears method was a great friend
and collaborator I'm sad to tell you
that he passed away
yesterday after a long and wonderful and
and very fruitful life so maybe let me
take this opportunity to to to to to
remember what a wonderful guy he was and
and how lucky I was to be able to work
with him for many years uh to kind of
try and make a joke let me tell you that
I had this title in a conference a few
years ago before Co and there was a big
snowstorm and I could not go to the
conference so they put up a slide that
said no all of this and no Yan so today
at least I I am here ER I have worked
for a long time on something that we
used to call we call equation free and
this is my little demo of how to work
equation free with complex systems this
is based on a paper by a friend a very
talented Australian mathematician Tony
Roberts this is two movies of the same
thing so I'm playing two movies of the
same thing wait a minute I have to play
the movie so here is the movie H let me
stop it and tell you what you're seeing
on the left is as a complex system it is
a whole bunch of dots it's Dot is
supposed to be a microorganism they are
kind of um a plankton on the surface of
the ocean they give birth they die they
do random Works they're sosed around by
random currents in the ocean on the
right what you see is the right
macroscopic observable the pair
correlation function that tells you how
many neighbors everybody has on average
as a function of the neighborhood size
I'm going to continue the movie what I
want you to see is that on the left it
is a horrible thing where you run and
see dots going around and they are sosed
and there's trations and it never
repeats itself on the right what you see
is in effect a very nice partial
differential equation that evolves and
goes to steady state with a little noise
so the point is these are two different
ways of looking at the same problem one
on the left is the microscopic
stochastic messy whatever so you can run
it and the only thing that you can do is
run it and describe bit to your friends
on the right if you can write the
partial differential equation for the
pair correlation function it's something
that you can integrate you can write
fixed Point algorithms you can write
stability calculations you can design
controllers for It Whatever the point is
H the form on the left is something you
can only simulate with the form on the
right you can simulate you can bifurcate
you can do stability there's so many
things that you can do if you have a
nice differential
model and so here is an example from
2000 with Bill gear on something that we
called course projective integration
which is how to solve equations at the
microscopic level without writing them
down let me kind of try and explain so
we have a particle code on the top we
have a particle code for which we don't
know the macroscopic closure but we
believe very much that the closure
exists
and we kind of even know what the right
microscopic observable is for this
equation the pair correlation function
how do I know it because I'm Tony
Roberts's friend and I read his paper so
I know there exists a macro equation but
I don't know how to write it down and I
say if I integrated this equation what
would I need I would need an initial
condition at the macroscopic level and a
Time derivative at the microscopic level
to do an Oiler
step yes but I don't have the equation
so what do I do I take the macroscopic
initial condition pair correlation
function I create particles that have
this pair correlation function we call
this thing lifting making microscopic
realizations consistent with a macro
description it's by no means trivial
sometimes it's easy sometimes it's
difficult then you run the particle code
for a short time it's like you do an
experiment with the particle code and
You observe the results observed on the
macro variable and after a short
integration you estimate the time
derivative of the macro variable and
then you use the time derivative
estimated not evaluated from a model
estimated from a brief burst of
simulation to make a big Oiler
step then you start again take the macro
initial condition make it particles run
a little bit estimate the time
derivative make a step so you see it's
kind of a closure on demand approach you
don't know what the equation is you have
however the micro code in your pocket
and you say if I integrated the micro
equation the macro equation what would I
need a Time derivative let me do just a
little burst of simulation to get this
number and do an Oiler step and then
just a little simulation there to
estimate the macro time derivative and
another Oiler step so the idea is you do
not have the equation but you don't try
to learn the equation you say if I had
the equation what would I need for from
it I would need a derivative I would
need the Jacobian okay then do just
enough appropriately initialized bursts
of micro simulation to get these numbers
and go on with the calculation you solve
the equation without writing it down we
called it equation free because it was a
time in my life that I like very much
Matrix free methods you realize all is
not free because there are equations at
the micro level it is the macro equation
that you don't know okay so this is the
equation free part you solve them
without learning them or writing them
down doing just enough on demand micro
simulation the big thing which is the
variable three is that in what I told
you I told you that you can do a better
use of the micr code but you need to
know what the right macroscopic
observables are in this example that I
showed you I already knew that the pair
correlation function is a macro
observable in terms of which I could in
principle derive a macro equation but
who told me this right I told you that I
read it in the paper so the question is
if we have a microscopic complex problem
and we kind of suspect we could write
macroscopic descriptions what are the
variables in terms of which we would
write the macroscopic descriptions and
traditionally you can either do it by
having let's say a systematic hierarchy
like for example you have you have
clouds of particles you use moments of
the distribution of the particles you
keep enough moments then it's a good
enough description hopefully
then you can have um experience
expertise knowledge Brilliance you know
you somebody could look at the particle
and say ah it is the pair correlation
function you should observe this could
be extremely difficult you know going
for example from the boltzman equation
to the nav Stokes is is is Generations
worth of brilliant mathematical work or
somebody maybe has very good intuition
about what to pay attention to and then
the thing that's the huge difference in
the last maybe so many years is that
instead of trying to figure it out by
experience or Brilliance we basically
you know go to the computer science
department and do machine learning on
the data to find out what the right
macro observables are so doing manifold
learning or machine learning to get the
right macro
observables so there's a long tradition
on on on on on trying to do model
reduction getting the data the Micro
Data that are very rich and then finding
good Lo descriptions that are
macroscopic reduced descriptions the
traditional one is principal component
analysis it's singular value DEC
composition it's around for 130
years and then this is something from
1992 which is very 1991 was the first
paper that I know it was by a guy called
Mark Kramer at MIT he called it
nonlinear principal component analysis
which is what today we call Auto
encoders take very high dimensional
descriptions write the bottleneck neural
network train it to learn the identity
then maybe these variables in the middle
are good reduced variables and then in
2000 but I want you to understand when
we were using all of this back then uh
this is a horrific nonlinear non-convex
optimization problem training a network
like that and back then it took us days
and days and weeks for this to converge
now it can be done in like seconds or
milliseconds so it was very difficult to
do it and so it was completely amazing
to me around the year 2000 that there
were a couple of backto back papers in
in Science magazine one on isomap and
the other on local line embedding and my
particular manifold learning tool since
I work with Rafi kman also is diffusion
Maps which was not learn hyperplanes
passing through the data but learn low
dimensional curved manifolds passing
through the data H and the amazing thing
in this is that you could take High
dimensional data here three-dimensional
and figure out that they are low
dimensional here two- dimensional and
also find a set of coordinates on the
low dimensional data not by solving a
nonlinear non-convex optimization
problem but by actually solving an igen
problem to me that was just you know
like out of the clear sky there was
thunder right you can create an N
problem and find what the right course
variables are so this is a kernel based
method diffusion Maps there is you know
many many of them these days in many
ways they are related or comparable some
body could be a little better for this
type of data or that type of data but
the idea is you worry what are good
observables in terms of which to write
macro equations I'll do some data mining
and here it
comes so now I want to I told you that
I'm going to tell you some old stuff
from 1992 so these are things on machine
learning that were lost in the Years
2000 until
2015 H this is a paper of of of mine uh
from 1992 it is in a very weird Journal
you would never read chemical
engineering Communications it has a
horrific title that would never make it
appetizing for somebody to read it's
called discrete versus continuous time
nonlinear signal processing of copper
electrod solution data and it is very
experimental and it was done in the lab
of this guy who Jack Hudson who was a
very good nonlinear Dynamics
experimentalist why am i showing you
this old thing so this is time series
from corrosion actually it was a Dara
ground for studying corrosion back then
so you have a chunk of metal you put it
in an acid and it dissolves this is a
Time series of the dissolution rate here
as time goes on it is steady and then it
is oscillatory and it is more messy
these are different values of the
potential between the metal and and the
reference electrode so you change a
parameter and you go from steady to
oscillatory to messy oscillatory and if
you use time delays so tens embeddings
then you have a steady state in a face
portrait and then you see a limit cycle
and a period doubling and here is a
period four and here is chaotic stuff
and the point is you have all of these
time dependent time series how do you
learn the dynamical system and how do
you also learn its dependence on a
parameter and this is what we did in you
know back then so it's already 30
years so here is auta
and here is a recurrent resonant based
on Ruta or motivated by Ruta that we did
in order to learn the dynamical system
from discrete time data look at what the
Ruta does you take an initial condition
Y and you calculate F the right hand
side you call this K1 you take this K1
you multiply it with the time step add
it to the initial condition and
calculate F of that then take this
multiply it by small number add it to
the initial condition so it is f of f of
f of F and if you look at what happens
here this is the data at time n this is
the data at time n + one and what you
see is that you take the data you pass
it through a neural network that we
learn the right hand side take a result
multiply it by a constant add it to the
beginning pass it through the same
neural network the same parameters four
times so this is a Rec current neural
network which trained on discrete time
data learns the right hand side of the
equation an approximation of the right
hand side of the equation also please
look it is a resonate it does not learn
the the result it learns the result as a
sum of what we started with plus
something that is lives in the Subspace
spaned by these other function
evaluation so if you want there is a
linear layer here at the top and this
would also remind you very much of krill
of methods so as a matter of fact this
is the kind of thing that I like to say
uh that in my mind many of the
algorithms that many of the
architectures that have been extremely
successful here you see both the current
networks and resets they are already
there in our traditional numerical
analysis if we just kind of look for
them there so by getting the time series
and then doing autoencoders on them to
find good variables and then using
recurrent resets what we did ah this is
to remind you that I I I expect all of
you or most of you already know this
this is the reset that became
fashionable that was was proposed in
2015 my paper has I think 95 citations
from 1992 this I think has 120,000
citations already uh reset is really
forward Oiler you can kind of see it you
take an initial condition you take it
and then you add to it a function times
a small number what is the difference
between the two mathematically not much
but the important thing is what is the
application that this was used for
compared to maybe the application that
we did which was copper electrode
dissolution data in
1992 but my point in this it's a very
nice idea don't learn the time one map
learn the time derivative learn the
right hand side but um uh again my main
point is this is this is forward Oiler
so the idea is that look at the
traditional algorithms there's very nice
analogies with what we are learning H
and again the variables came from doing
auto encoders back in
1992 and what you see here is observed
and reconstructed attractors and time
series and the bifurcation diagram that
you get from the time dependent discrete
time single variable observed model uh
and so my point again here you know me
being older and is that hey a lot of
these things were done back then and not
just by me this just happens to be
something I
did and we did a lot of more things back
then for example remember the main idea
is create neural network architectures
that are based on traditional numerical
algorithms so here is an implicit neural
network which is not a feed forward
neural network but evaluating it needs
necessitates solving algebraic equations
and this is very simply an architecture
that comes from the crank Nicholson or
from the trapezoidal rule so we did a
lot of things about how to
train uh implicit networks if you want
also back then again motivated by
traditional numerical algorithms another
thing that we did is the gray
boxes remember if you know if you don't
know an equation then you can learn the
right hand side of the equation with a
black box you know multi-layer
perceptron but if you know the equation
so so here we know parts of the equation
but we don't know one nonlinear reaction
term then you can create a neural
network architecture that is a gray box
architecture hardwire is the part that
you know and only learns the part that
you don't know this is from
1994 and this is 1993 again sorry for
all the old stuff but you know I hope
maybe it is of some interest so we had
movies uh you mentioned Gard erle who
from Berlin at the fritz hubber
Institute who got the Nobel Prize in
chemistry in 2007 so so this is working
with him in
1993 what you see at the top is
snapshots from videos you see I don't
have these you know they came in VHS
tapes and what you see is concentration
patterns on the surface of a catalyst um
more red is more carbon monoxide and
more blue is more oxygen and you see
that there is oscillations so after some
time you come back to the same picture
and so on and so forth so we had these
movies and then what did we do we took
these movies first we did data mining we
did principal components on the movies
and that gave us four principal
components pods if you want and what we
did then is that we learned an
approximate inertial form that is we
learned the movie became then four time
series of the time dependent components
of the empirical basis functions so the
movie became four time series uh these
are the four time series the four
coefficients of the first second third
fourth empirical spatial basis functions
and then what we did is that we use
neural networks here with history so you
see there is the four components now the
four coefficients and the four
coefficients at the previous time step
and then giving those we are learning
what the four coefficients will be at
the next time step you can think of this
as either learning with history you can
think of it as a version although it's
not exactly fair to to to to to call it
like that but you know it is it's the
the same it's it's a comparable idea
with long short time memory networks you
see that there is uh the both the
current and previous versions not the
same but you you you use some history in
being able to determine what happens
forward in time and what you see is that
we could reproduce the movies in a very
nice way and the attractors these are
the attractors projected on various
different empiric Ally found through
principal
components latent spaces so here the
latent space was done through principal
components uh this is something again
from back then this is from experimental
data in R benar
convection this is with Bob eki who was
a post with me at losal when we were
both young and who later was a director
of CNS and he was doing ra berar
convection in super fluid liquid helium
and the behavior was quasi periodic and
what you see here is delay
reconstructions of the Quasi periodic
attractors from R benar convection and
what you see here is again having neural
networks that dependent on the a number
this is this neuron for R here in order
to learn the panap that came from the
experimental observations of R benar
convection and there's all kinds of
details and bifurcations and I think
this is more or less what I'm going to
tell you about old stuff oh no there's
something more about old stuff so in
what I showed you I showed you how to
learn Odes or Maps so continuous or
discrete low dimensional systems from
data but then what we also did is that
we learned partial differential
equations for data so this is operator
learning think of a parabolic PD I mean
what is a parabolic PD there is a
relation between the time derivative at
a point and then the value and some
spatial derivatives on the right hand
side so if somebody
gives you so this is a paper from
98 suppose that somebody gives you
SpaceTime movies from a PD then you sit
at some moment in space time you look at
the nearby stencil the value of the
solution at a few nearby points with
finite differences you estimate
derivatives and then given the parameter
and these derivatives you train a neural
network to learn that time derivative at
the central point so this is a
convolutional neural net Network for
these Five Points here is a copy of the
network then you shift in Space by one
then you have a copy of the same network
shift by one same copy so this is a
convol so finite differences again as
most or all of you know finite
difference algorithms correspond
completely to having convolutional
neural networks in space and what we did
is that we combined the if you want
convolutional neural networks in space
with the rec current neural networks in
time to learn partial differential
equations from SpaceTime data and this
was um this is a Burgers it's a very
simple example I mean these were toy
examples but again I want to make a
point that a lot of the things that we
know now and do much better or much
faster and more intelligently now they
were already known back then let me show
you something more recent so that I
don't only tell you old stuff what if
the partial differential equation comes
from observation at the course level of
microscopic things so this is a paper
about bacterial chemotaxis this is
something that comes from our work two
years ago not 30 years ago and what I'm
going to show you uh let me maybe tell
you a couple of things so what I'm going
to show you is microscopic simulations
of 10,000 if I remember correctly agents
each agent is supposed to be a materium
it is a set of differential stochastic
equations it has two in internal
continuous States plus six random
variables that are the flagella whether
they are going clockwise or
counterclockwise how the flagel it's a
it's a
fascinating physiological system the
motion of eoli but for the purposes of
our discussion you have five or 10,000
agents Each of which is a set of
differential
stochastic ordinary differential and
stochastic equations and they run and
depending on whether the flagel are
going clockwise or counterclockwise the
thing is running or tumbling and the
whole point is you want a description
not of what each agent does but the
entire bacterial density so you want
macroscopic chemotactic equations from
agent based simulations and that's what
you see
here here are 5,000 5,000 bacteria and
they are colored blue yellow or green
depending on whether they're moving to
the right to the left or tumbling in
place and what we do is that we run the
bacteria and from observing the bacteria
at the macroscopic level that is by
looking at the evolution of the density
of the bacteria we learn a partial
differential equation a chemotactic
partial differential equation for the
motion of the bacterial density look we
start the bacteria at a location in
space that this this is original bump
this this comes from a density estimator
the green is the food so the bacteria I
want to move to the right go to the
place where there is a lot of food I'm
going to play the movie on the left you
see the microscopic agent based
simulation on the center you see two
plots the red and the blue the red is
the PDF of what you see on the right the
blue is the effective Evolution that
comes from a partial differential
equation for the chemotactic evolution
of the bacterial density that is the
coar grain version of the problem that
was learned the way that I showed you as
we did it back then in
1998 H so what's the difference now the
difference is you don't learn macro
stuff from macro data you learn macro
stuff from Micro Data and there is an
extra little twist in the next page you
see at the top here it says results and
then says gray boxes and as far as you
presenting it the movie is exactly the
same just trust me that here we learn
the partial differential equation not
for the entire Black Box PD right hand
inside but only for the chemotactic part
the diffusion part we kind of hardwired
because we knew
it um this is also something new er you
remember that we used numerical schemes
rutas finite differences as templates to
create neural networks to learn ODS and
PDS this is something which is recent
and it is it's on archive for a year or
so but it's unpublished um we are are
using again stochastic numerical
integrators Oiler maruyama milstein hin
in order to take data from stochastic
time series and learn effective SDS
drifts and state dependent diffusivities
this is um just a loss function is where
the numerical method goes this is an
example you see here
evolution of stochastic you know statch
type calculations agents on a ltis it
happens to have something to do with sir
and and epidemics but this is just an an
observ and you know that as you run
these there is limits at which you know
that there exist mean field equations uh
there can be mean field deterministic
and mean field stochastic equations so
we take the data from the stochastic
large run and we use this technology
that I told you which is neural networks
templated on numerical integrators in
this case just oer marama in order to
learn an effective drift and an
effective
diffusivity so again the main message
look at your traditional numerical
methods your traditional numerical
methods are very well linked with
architectures uh for learning dynamical
systems from data with neural networks
of course you can learn these functions
with neural networks with kernels with
gausian processes which we also play
with there so there's many many
interesting tools for doing that what is
interesting maybe one of the interesting
things is the gray book
the combination of the parts that you
know with the parts that you don't know
so I kind of have told you I'm kind of
halfway through I told you about no
equations no variables I didn't tell you
about no parameters that you have kind
of have to trust me and I want to talk
to you about the fun part which is no
space and no time so in 2011 I think
DARPA had a contest it was called the
shredder Challen the shredding Challenge
and what they did is that they took five
documents and they shredded them and
they put the stuff on the web and they
paid $50,000 to whoever would put the
documents back together again and um a
month later I think San Francisco
company solved most of them and got the
$50,000 and my students now and your
students and you can do this in I don't
know half an hour ER what's the basic
idea basic idea is the same as uh you
know our kids solve puzzles this is a
partial differential equation it's a
messy one it's a Ginsburg low one space
Dimension and time this is the SpaceTime
plot that comes from a big
simulation and what you do is that you
take this page as it comes out of the
printer and what you do is that you go
to the office Shredder and you shred it
into 512 time series you just take the
paper and feed it through the shredder
and then you get many time series and
then you mix them up so you know what
happens but you don't know know where in
space it
happens the idea is that if you take
each one of these time series that are
mixed up now you don't know which one
comes from which point in time and then
you consider each one of these time
series as a data point and then what you
do is that you put these you try to find
which data point is close to which data
point as functions in time then what you
would find if you do even principal
components in these 500 and 12 time
series you would find that they are a
one parameter family of Time series and
if you order them based on their first
principal component what you would do is
that you would recover the topology of
the original space so you understand you
take a Time series you just try to find
among all the other ones which is
closest you find two that are closest
you put one on the right and one on the
left you're actually not sure which
should be on the right and which should
be on the left so what we recover here
if you're very careful you will see it
is a flip of what we had at the
beginning do do I do you see what I'm
saying right you take the thing you
shred it you have many time series you
don't know where they're coming from
thinking of these time series as data
you can recover the topology of the
original
space if somebody if it is if somebody
really hates what I just said it was
really badly unclear it's a good time to
say do you see what is done you take a
movie you make it into a puzzle then you
give it to a kid in this case the kid is
diffusion maps and then you ask it can
you put the puzzle Back Together Again
by looking at similarity you can put the
puzzle back together
again okay yes good so next
slide this is the same thing in two
space dimensions and time you take a 2
dpd space and time you take it through a
meat grinder I don't know if you have
seen one I remember one as a kid and
then out of the meat grinder come Oodles
of Time series and you mix them all
together and you don't know who is
coming from whom but by looking at which
time series is close to which time
series then you can get a
two-dimensional you realize there are
two parameter family of Time series
diffusion Maps or ISO map or TI or
whatever your favorite poison is will
tell you that it's a two-dimensional
family of data and if you order them in
this data driven latent space
autoencoders would also do that
then you kind of see that what you get
is something that is one to one a
homeomorphism or diffeomorphism if you
want of the original space so if this
this tells you if you have Behavior but
you don't know what the space was then
look similarity of behavior and create a
space in which nearby behaviors happen
at nearby
places here's how to think of it you
agree with me all that play with
numerics that that if you discretize
this with finite differences you're
going to get the pent diagonal matrix
yes you know who is the equation next to
you on the right on the left and further
down yes to do this to do this you must
order the nodes 1 2 3 4 5 10 11 12 13 20
21 okay you you kind of have to order
the nodes in some particular way if you
don't number the nodes that way but you
number them randomly then the finite
difference Jacobian becomes a horrific
adjacency Matrix of some crazy Network
it's the same thing it's just you've
labeled them randomly but if you have
these random labels and look at what
happens at each label then you can
reconstruct the original space okay so
the idea is take the behavior and if you
don't know what the space is create
through data mining a space in which the
behavior looks smooth this is a good
Lattin space for observing the behavior
let me show you a nice example of this
so the physicist apologies if
I I understand that in physics the word
emergent space is used for something
like this that is a space that is not a
physical space but a space in which the
behavior appears nice it's a it's a
space that fits the behavior if you want
here is a bunch here's an example this
is from Steve stroets who is a wizard
with oscillators and also is an amazing
writer for those of you that know him or
read his stuff and uh here is 800
oscillation
they are not frequency illers they're
they're 800 coupled illers okay and they
are colored by these are the initial
conditions for each one of them they are
colored by some random magic color and
what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to simulate all of these couple Doats
and what you will find is that they
organize themselves along a
onedimensional curve which later on
evolves and somehow you see that this
magic color it has to do very much with
the ordering that they have on this
curve so here is an extremely complex
system that if you know how to plot it
and that is what you're going to see
again here this is the angle of this
curve as a function of the color and
this is the amplitude of the curve as a
function of the color and you will agree
with me that it looks like a PD If Only
You Knew What is the right dimension in
which to plot the
behavior so here is the same idea a
whole bunch of oscillators they start at
X and Y initial conditions and you run
them and then you see that they if if
you know what is this magical third
dimension in which you plot them then
they really look like a partial
differential equation in this emergent
Dimension so here is exactly the same
idea that I was telling you again here
is all the oscillators here how they
evolve in time they organize themselves
along a curve if you look along the
curve and you plot them by where they
started you get a very bad function it's
not what they started at that determines
what happens what actually determines
what happens is how heterogeneous they
are the thing that matters is their
intrinsic frequency so what does this
mean take a whole bunch of oscillators
each one of them is going to do stuff
you plot them from one to 200 and
whatever it looks like a horrible mess
of spaghetti if you take all of these
and you do data mining on the
trajectories and you rearrange them
then you find a magical variable and
this magical variable if you plot them
as a function of this magical variable
in time then it looks like a partial
differential equation so this variable
is an emergent independent
coordinate okay you even use data to
find the space in which you should look
at the data and here is this partial
differential
equation plotted as a function of the
emergent coordinate the data driven
emergent independent the thing that
plays the role of space okay and as a
function of time and now remember how I
told you if I have SpaceTime data I can
learn PDS okay so we find the right
space and in the right space it looks
like a PD and then we go and learn this
PD and what you see here is the
bifurcation diagram of the behavior of
these
eight course grain behavior of these
oscillators plotted as a function of the
parameter you see there is coherent
steady state here and then there is a
parameter value at which you get
coherent SpaceTime oscillations this is
a PD not in physical space but in an
emerging space that came from
observation of the
data uh this is a two-dimensional
emerging space let me okay I think the
let me let me show you an example that's
more interesting so this is a version of
computational Neuroscience what you have
is a th
24 neurons each of the neurons is a
bunch of differential equations here too
they're all heterogeneous the kinetic
parameters are different they are all
structurally heterogeneous they are
coupled in a network which is not all to
all it's a Chung glue Network this has
something to do with the suprachiasmatic
nucleus it doesn't matter it's just a
model many coupled dilators and what you
see here is what these oscillators do
when they are running around because
they're different each one of them does
a slightly different oscillation if you
take these oscillations and do data
mining in these oscillations you will
find that they are really a two
parameter family of oscillations and you
can think of each neuron as a point in
an emerging space in which emerging
space where the variables are data
driven 51 52 it has two spatial
dimensions in this emerging space nearby
neurons are nearby
points and if you look at the behavior
in this space space then and that's what
you see here these is the emerging space
coordinates the data driven space
coordinates and this is a partial
differential equation describing the
network not as this is what node one
does node two node 55 but in effect
telling you that your network is a
discretization of a
manifold so trying to find a space in
which your network is in effect a
discretization of a
Continuum once we find the right space
then we can go in and learn the partial
differential equations for the evolution
so this is learning PDS in emergent
space let me throw in
something if you go back to this
emerging space if you color this
emerging Space by the kinetic
heterogenity that I happen to know I
actually find that this emergent
variable is one to one with a kinetic
heterogenity and the other kinetic
variable is one to one with the degree
of the neuron in the network so if you
want this variable has more to do with
the structure with the kinetic
heterogenity and the other variable has
to do more with the structural
heterogenity so this is an attempt to to
at explainability of the coordinates
that were found by data
M bottom line look at Messi data find
the space in which the Messi data look
nice learn the operator in this data DP
driven emerging
space now in what I showed you I showed
you uh shredding a
movie at fixed points in time in in
space along the time Direction so I
shredded the movie vertically here I
take the movie The SpaceTime PD movie
and shred it horizontally that is I kind
of it's like you take a movie and some
scissors and then you cut the movie in
many places and then you mix all of the
pictures so you don't know what the
right order in time is the same idea can
be used to take things that are mixed up
in time and find the right order in time
and in general you can take a movie and
take a cookie cutter and kind of chop it
in SpaceTime little patches and mess
them all up it is possible to put them
back together nicely again with data
mining and then you can go in this
SpaceTime that is emergent space time
and learn the right Evolution law what I
basically am telling you is that if you
think think of a partial differential
equation this is the kuramoto shinski
this is space this is time and this is
evolution this is a traveling wave and
you see that it's modulated so it's a
modulated traveling wave one frequency
from traveling one frequency for
modulation this is a torque what I'm
basically telling you is that whether
you sit at points in space and look at
Short Time series or whether you sit at
points in time and take little local
pictures or whether you sit at points in
SpaceTime and look at little patches or
whether you you have traveling observers
and you could be recording what the
traveling observers have been observing
you can take all of these very very
different data and register them that is
you can create an emerging space in
which all of them are onet to one with
each other so this is gaug and variant
data mining that is as long as you have
different observations of the same data
it is possible to do your data mining in
such a way that as long as I mean you
may observing things from different
observation sources but as long as your
instruments are informative enough then
you can map what the one instrument does
to what the other instrument does you
can fuse information from many different
sources here is the basic idea you kind
of all know that when we do data mining
the important thing in data mining is to
have sort of similarity between two
measurements something that you can use
in a kernel right what's the distance
between two
measurements okay so let's say that this
is the a sort of divine space or
platonic space that is the true nature
of the behavior and on this side it's
how yanis sees the behavior and then on
the other side is how yungu sees their
behavior and
um so the point is we have two different
events what is important in data mining
is a sort of similarity measure between
the two
events um let's say that this is Janis
and the blue curve is janis's way of
looking at the universe that is my own
glasses okay uh you see
that what I see is not exactly what is
seen by Plato but it is at least one to
one my my observation function is one to
one with the
truth and uh what you're want you to see
here then is that if I have two events
happening they have some distance in
platonic space but through my bad
observation curve they're going to have
a different distance in my space so if I
do data mining of my observational data
I'm going to get something completely
different than the
truth here is what would happen if yungu
looked at the data and the green is
yung's observation curve so in his Cas
the distance between two data points are
going to be very different then his
kernel will be very different and he
will compute very different things here
is the little magical part if when you
measure the data points you don't just
and this was done by a mid singer to my
knowledge a mid singer and Rafi quman in
2008 they had an um app in computational
harmonic analysis paper and they called
it anisotropic diffusion notes if you
don't just measure the data points but
you also sprinkle a little gaussian
around the data points and measure this
little gausian and then in my world I
look at how this little gausian deformed
and yungu in his world sees how his
gausian deformed if we looked at this
observation and we use this to estimate
the slope the local slope of our glasses
and use this local slope to rescale the
distance as I see it and he sees it then
in effect what we do is that we can
create if you look at this we can kind
of create a lens if you look at this
green red curve it's a sort of way that
allows us to do data mining in such a
way that both what I see and both what y
sees can be mapped to the same reference
truth so that no matter what my
observation function is and what his
observation function is we can agree
that what he sees and what I see is a
realization of a common reference
representation so again what I'm telling
you is that I can have very different
observations of the same phenomenon and
do the data mining in such a way that I
can that both I and and yungu would have
the same processed reference image of
the data we have a little paper with ra
equipment this can be done by igen
problems but in particular we have a
paper that showed up last year it's
called Loca for local conformal
autoencoders it's an autoencoder you can
kind of see it but the point is every
point is not just mapped to another
point but we are trying to take the
neighborhood of a point and then map it
to A Perfect Circle here so the idea is
that if we have very different
observations then we're going to get
different neighborhoods of each
observation using this Auto encoder or
map it into a version of the problem
that would be common for all different
observations this is an an illustration
of this let's say that this is the
original space this is one nonlinear
observation of the space you see it has
been deformed into a mushroomy thing
this is a different linear you see it's
rotated and distorted these are two very
different representations of the same
thing if we do this data gauge this
gauge invariant data mining then both of
them are mapped to squares that are
within an orthogonal transformation of
each other so it is very interesting to
consider as I said reconciling very
different observations of the same thing
and fusing them to create a nice space
in which to learn the
model we did this for you know suppose
that you have two different neural
network two different cameras that look
at the same thing then we have something
that learns what this cameras SE and the
point is in a data driven way can we
create a mapping from what one neural
network learned to what the other neural
network learn as long as they are
different Rich enough observations of
the same thing then it is possible to
map them you can maybe see why something
like that is important the way that
we're working now with the same data you
give the same data to I don't know
Hopkins we are going to get a learned
machine learned model for them yungu at
Lawrence Livermore will take another one
and um the point is did we learn the
same thing so it's important to be able
to take my model and your model and see
if these two models are really just
invertible transformations of each
other so this is a talk from many years
ago this just the title it's kind of
funny okay that in a sense we're
becoming more medieval we take data and
without understanding what the right
variables are the right variables come
from Data Mining and without being able
to actually understand mechanistically
what the operators are the operators
also come from machine learning we can
make predictions Without Really knowing
mechanistically what happens it's not
exactly of course you would immediately
say like that it is that U we understand
the algorithms that process the data we
don't maybe understand mechanistically
what exactly the terms
mean and so this is to kind of entertain
you at the end of the talk because it's
already
155 this is Plato remember I already
told you about Plato and Socrates here
in the middle is the Academy of
Athens in in in the Renaissance people
understood a perspective uh you know the
projective plane the point at Infinity
that straight lines meet at infinity and
they started for the first time painting
exactly what they saw you should think
of this as a model of the world you're
making a model that looks exactly like
what you see and people put a lot of
effort in being able to make a model of
exactly what they saw and then
photography came by and it was too easy
to do it and so people started to try to
express what they feel when they see
something this is the cedral and then
and you it's painted in different
weathers let's say and so if you think
of the truth and you make a model of the
truth you take a mirror okay you would
like a model of the truth to be as close
to the truth as possible right and if
the model is imperfect then you get
something that is kind of like the truth
but not exactly like the truth like if
you go to a Luna Park and you know they
have these deformable mirrors and you
walk in front of them and you can kind
of understand that it's you but it's a
deformed version of you
we are very much used to the idea of
having models that are slight
distortions of the truth and what I'm
kind of telling you is the opposite idea
is there a chance that the truth we see
this is a version of it this is another
version of it this is another version is
there maybe a space in which the truth
is more beautiful is there a
transformation of our model to normal
form to l it for example through kman
where I also play among with good
friends like Igor mesit a a
transformation to something integrable a
transformation to something hamiltonian
would it be interesting to not to think
that we want something that represents
exactly what we see but is it possible
to create a transformation that makes
the difficult problem that we are seeing
easier to solve can we use machine
learning in order to construct cool hops
to construct equpments to
construct I don't know inverse
scuttering Transformations or back so
the the idea is and in my opinion this
is kind of where I want to leave you I
think this is one of the really great
things about machine learning we don't
have to make our models just in terms of
the things that we understand we can
also make all kinds of Transformations
for them and so map them to spaces where
they're easier to compute easier to
observe easier to whatever is not an
original idea but machine learning
allows us not to find just beautiful
closed form Transformations but allows
us to work with Transformations that are
data driven and we can of course fuse
different views of the truth back to the
truth so what I will finish with uh I
have two minutes and I didn't leave you
time for questions but maybe bear with
me H I don't know how many of you know
Juna Lahiri she was in some sense a
colleague in Princeton she teaches also
creative writing there she um you know
she wrote The Interpreter of mades and
she wrote the namesake if you ever saw
the movie and that some point she
decided to write in Italian I think she
was married to an Italian is and wrote a
book called in other words you see this
here and she wrote it in Italian and got
somebody to translate it and I'm going
to read to you a couple of pieces from
the afterward of the book it's an
exquisitely crafted book and for many
many pages it keeps sh saying in
wonderful Pros how difficult it is to
translate things from one language to
the other and I want you to understand
translating from one language to the
other is the most quintessential
everyday gauge transformation it is the
same idea but you write it in Italian
words or in English words okay and after
spending we're talking about
translation and and and and after
writing a whole book on how difficult it
is to
express things easy to say in English in
Italian and express things that are easy
to say in Italian in English she writes
this afterward which is to me it was
absolutely breathtaking when I read it
she says in 1939 15 years before he died
Anri matis began to move away from
traditional painting and develop a new
artistic technique it involved cutting
up pieces of paper that had been painted
in gouache in various colors think
pixels matis then combined the pixels
and arranged the different pixels to
create an image he fixed the elements
first with pins then with paste on your
screen often directly on the wall he
stopped using the easel the canvas his
main tool became a pair of scissors
rather than the brush the method a sort
of synthesis of collag and Mosaic arose
out of certain limitations the eyesight
of the guy was not working and he had a
serious illness and he had to use his
assistants you know your great post
books and graduate students it was a
collective
process uh the images on paper were more
simplified crude compared to the ones on
canvas but they required painstaking
complex workmanship the same way that
our machine learned models they are
maybe not as beautiful to understand as
the actual mechanistic ones but they
require painstaking complex workmanship
one recognizes the hand and the eye of
the painter but they have changed we
follow the thread between the new method
and the earlier paintings and are aware
of a turning point a radical move last
thing to read you for matis cutting and
for us machine learning based modeling
was not only a new technique but a
system for thinking about and expanding
the possibilities of shape color and
composition a rethinking of his artistic
strategy a rethinking of our modeling
strategy the painter said the conditions
of this journey are 100% different he
compared his method which he called
painting with scissors to the experience
of flying and when we talk about this
with Rafi kman my my friend and
colleague and Mentor he always says yeah
but we have codes that do that okay
thank you that was
it thank you thank thank you so much for
the wonderful talk I I really enjoyed it
I'm sure um everyone else enjoyed it a
lot thank you I hope I I told you a lot
of things all of them simple I hope I
was reasonably coherent anyway it was
coherent you you you do have a um one um
you know the common you know the theme
you would like to address here I can see
that from your talk yeah okay so we do
have a questions I mean although it's a
past one hour but we we don't stop there
usually maybe ion since I see your hand
Aon all right um do you want to unmute
yourself and ask questions because I I
don't I don't see
your Jerome yeah Jerome you can unmute
yourself question I just hi um thank you
for your talk I just was reminded with
your your discussion at the end of uh of
the there was a like book by Nim Talib
who's kind of a stock market guy but
also the Red Queen yeah that guy right
and uh he was he had this long anecdote
one of his books about a stock uh a guy
who was like the world expert in pork
belly futures or something like that um
and a
like Talib uh talked to him a bunch and
finally figured out that even though
this guy could tell you like what the
effect of the war in Ukraine or or a
revolution or any other like world event
would have on pork Billy Futures he
actually didn't know what pork Billy
Futures really were right I I yeah thank
you I I also appreci I mean I didn't
know about this specific one but my way
of talking about what you said do you
remember vice president cheny he said
there is known unknowns and unknown
unknowns so you're right there is people
that are capable of predicting but they
do not necessarily know what why However
the fact that they can means there does
exist a function right right yeah right
yeah I I I appreciate I didn't know
about this if you would be so kind and
email me this I mean you all I'm sure of
stories like you know there is this
great politician and he gets his shoes
Polished in the morning I hope he not
politically incorrect what I'm saying
and and and the you know the person who
shines the shoes who has I don't know
what he has observed know can tell them
tips for the stock market or something
ER one of the jokes that I like to say I
don't know if it's a good one is you
when I talk to a lot of students you
know I I'm sure in your company there is
somebody when they see a new couple form
they say ah these guys they will last a
week or ah these guys they will get
married and uh maybe they know what it
is that they are why they say this or
maybe they don't know but at least the
good thing for us is the belief that
there exists a function sorry I said the
same thing several times but I
understand what you're saying and I
appreciate it and it also does scare me
a little bit right I mean it is a little
bit medieval like we can predict but
it's it's like the the magician I mean
there there is an oracle and you ask the
question and you get an answer and you
don't know if it's true so how many
times do you have
to you know do you believe it if if you
get good answers a lot of times you tend
to believe
it anyway how well does it generalize
yes somebody else thank you all right um
so and next question I can read from the
chat there's there are a couple of
questions well it's it's not a question
the Andre it's from the Andre uh fipo he
he left the comment about it is
necessary in his opinion it is necessary
to have a some idea about the type of
equations to understand what initial
condition and boundary conditions yeah
yeah yeah okay good so I will uh
interrupt so you're absolutely right so
in
2003 we wrote a
paper which then in 2007 was reproduced
in the S
reviews it has a very strange title the
the title is the baby bathwater scheme
and the subtitle says deciding the
nature of the unavailable equation which
is if you have a black box how do you
test if it's an OD if it's a PD if it's
an SD if it's a conservation law how
many equations does how many derivatives
does it have on the right hand side
these are not easy nor are the answers
unique but there is a wonderful idea
exactly what you said which is if you
have a black box what are the how do you
design experiments that will tell you
the qualitative things like how many
boundary conditions you use and you need
and what type and so on and so forth
that's a whole
wonderful maybe it's very naive of me to
say that way it's a whole wonderful
Branch if I have a black box how do I
figure out the nature of the operator in
the Black Box not the operator the
nature of the
operator let me give you a stupid the
most stupid of examples how do you tell
if something is an OD or an SD you run
it again if you get the same result
again and again then it is an OD if you
get a distribution of results it's
probably an SD I'm not saying this to is
not a definitive answer but in the same
way there is trust me if you start
thinking about it a little bit you're
going to find a lot of ways by which you
can probe the Black Box just enough to
estimate with some
with some conviction I issues about its
nature not its actual functional form
all right I know I make sense if you are
still there and care to ah good answer
okay good thank you all right great okay
so next question is from uh
FAL uh she said the thanks for the
fabulous talk um could you go back to
the slide about discovery of SD
stochastic differential equation
what kind of data was it trained on yeah
yeah so you get good point by the way um
not that I do this on purpose um there
is a lot of wonderful work in recent
papers I can tell you
several George kakis has some Jin Duan
has some there's lots and lots of papers
on learning SDS what is our twist okay
if you look if you look at this it
doesn't tell you very much I make a
neural network whose output you go in
with data you go in with pairs of data
now and after a Time step okay so you
you take whatever time series you you
have and you chop them into uh pairs
input output pairs X now X next next
moment in time and then you create a
neural network that learns the estimates
the drift and the diffusivity and all
the interesting part has to do with um
how do you take the data and from the
data you estimate the drift and the
diffusivity so maybe very simplistically
think about it if I have many copies at
the same point and I have the same time
step then I'm going to get the same
result but I mean the drift component
will be the same but then after one
Oiler maruyama time step you're going to
get a distribution of results right the
the the mean will the mean will tell you
something about the drift and the
distribution of the results will tell
you something about the
diffusivity again sorry this is a very
bare Bor so what were the data pairs
pairs of now and a step later you can
also make it several steps later and
again depending on what is the
integrator what whatever the stochastic
integrator that you use as a template
you have a different
loss you'll get a different loss when
you train with the same data and assume
they're coming from an oil maruyama a
different loss if they are assumed to be
coming
from milstein those two are in our paper
um maybe what is worth saying and I this
is not directly for what you asked now
when you use integrators as a template
of the right hand side then you don't
learn the dynamical system that produced
the data you learn a dynamical system
when which when integrated with this
integration Ator will pass from your
data this is a form of backward error
analysis not forward where you have the
equation and the result of the
integration and you estimate the error
here you estimate the difference between
two dynamical systems the one that
produced the data and the one that you
learn the one that you learn is the one
that when integrated numerically will
pass from the data this has a name it's
called God help us inverse backward
error analysis it is a class of backward
error analysis and um it would be very
interesting and I talk with Sebastian
Reich who is A coauthor on this and a
very good friend about inverse backward
error analysis for
stochastic integrators so there is stuff
that you know as far as I know has not
yet been done it's kind of traditional
numerical analysis but it hasn't been
done was I I I I was not completely
clear but did I at least give you
meaningful
answer yeah okay yes corre thanks thank
you great I mean he asked uh the
following question what's the most
important difference between discovery
of pde and
[Music]
sde um
okay well I mean when you try to learn a
PD then you have data that depend on
space and time or on a on on on
independent variables and time for an
SD you get discrete dime data right and
so the question is how do you
parameterize the map from data now and
here and now to data tomorrow maybe the
more important question is what the
previous gentleman asked you have
discrete time you have space time
discrete data the the main question is
are you going to try and model them with
an SD are you going to try and model
them with an SPD are you going to try
and model them let me kind of U so so
the qualitative question is very
important let me tell you something that
I learned in the last few years is not
that I learned it I realized in the last
few
years um there is no it's an obvious
statement if somebody gives you data
there is a million different equations
that pass from these data they can be
very different they are all consistent
with the data but very different from
each other so in what sense do you
believe that any one of these results is
the true
um this is a difficult question I mean
you you can find equations consistent
with the data H it's very tempting to
say I found the equation and actually
maybe you can call me guilty through
this entire talk I told you I wrote I I
learned the PD no wrong thank you for
maybe giving you learn a PD that passes
from the data let me also tell you we
even have papers on this we can the same
data can be learned can be parameterized
either with a partial differential
equation or with an integral equation or
with who knows what else so so it's
important to kind of have the feeling
that you learn a generator for the
data uh there is many different
generators possibly of different nature
also consistent with the same data let's
not kind of fool ourselves that we
learned the
law okay sounds good okay so I I see a
lot of um um complimentary comments
really nice talk that's nice if somebody
wants to learn something email me as you
see I like to talk too
much thank you very much for the amazing
talk and and Jack Walter said just
looked up the mattis's seizure paintings
yeah ah yes it's amazing okay thank you
all thank you for having me thank you
thank you so much
um um
the yest